la parole est à Monsieur Pierre Charon
pour le groupe
UMP monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le président de la commission des
finances monsieur le rapporteur général
monsieur le
rapporteur la création d'une banque
d'investissement est censé répondre aux
difficultés que rencontrent les
entreprises françaises pour trouver des
financements avant de détailler les
problèmes posés par une telle structure
je tiens à signaler mes chers collègues
qu'il aurait peut-être fallu commencer
par ne pas dissuader les investisseurs
d'investir leur argent en France en
alourissant la fiscalité sur les revenus
du capital car si les entreprises ont
effectivement besoin de capitaux pour se
développer vous conviendrez qu'il est un
peu hasardeux de taxer précisément le
carburant je peux parler plus fort que
vous vous savez j'ai la voix qu'il faut
de l'activité économique de notre pays
quand on taxe les cigarettes c'est pour
que les gens fument moins et bien quand
on taxe l'investissement les gens
investissent moins il faut ensuite
déployer des trésors de créativité
législative pour essayer de lutter
contre les effets néfastes de ce genre
de décision je voudrais maintenant
revenir à la réponse supposément
apportée par la création de la pays
merci monsieur le
Président pour commencer pourquoi public
si c'est pour faire le travail que font
les banques privées pourquoi alourdir
les dépenses de l'État et il s'agit pour
reprendre la formule de Jean-Pierre
jouillet collègue monsieur montescu
annoncé tout à l'heure financer les
fameux canards boiteux c'est alors
confondre investissement et Charité
alourdir la dépense publique qui pèsera
inévitablement sur l'activité c'est
porté atteinte à la compétitivité
monsieur le ministre je c que le choc de
compétitivité que vous proposez se
résume à un coup de matraque fiscal et
la création d'un organisme de charité
publique mes chers collègues je pense
qu'il faut que nous reconnaissions
aujourd'hui que l'État n'a pas toujours
été le gestionnaire le plus éclairé nous
avons tous en mémoire le triste exemple
du Crédit Lyonnais et de ces 130
milliards de perte plus récemment nous
nous souvenons tous des 31 milliards
d'euros de perte de Dexia dont la moitié
furent à la charge des contribu
et que TR interventions successives de
l'État n'ont pas suffis à sauver
d'autres chiffres encore fournis par
votre gouvernement en annexe du projet
de loi de finances de 2013 don le
rapport relatif à l'État actionnaire
devrait nous inviter à une certaine
humilité chacun se
reconnaîtra ainsi moi c'est très ce que
je dis on peut commenter les
inepsies Sion se réfère au dernier bilan
de taxes itionnaire entre l'été 2011 et
l'été 2012 la valeur des sociétés côté
détenu par l'État a reculé de près de 13
% durant la même période les entreprises
du CAC 40 progressaient de 5 % soit un
différentiel de près de 20 % quant aux
participations supérieur à 1 % que
l'État détient dans une cinquantaine de
groupes non côtés les dividendes sont en
recul de 2 milliards d'euros passant de
79 à 58 milliards
d'euros devant ce bilan merci mon cher
collègue et dans un contexte économique
déjà très fragilisé par les effets de la
crise il est permis de se poser la
question de la pertinence du choix d'une
banque publique pour assurer la mission
de financement des entreprise de demain
il est par ailleurs douteux d'imaginer
les présidents de région intervenir dans
90 % des choix des entreprise à soutenir
le métier de banquier c'est
l'appréciation du risque et pas pas
l'appréciation et pas l'appréciation
politique inspiré par le
clientélisme de plus par le clientélisme
local de plus le texte prévoit que la
BPI puisse être à la fois actionnaire et
prêteuse l'histoire financière récente a
démontré combien ce mélange des genes
était dangereux pour une banque les
entreprises n'attendent d'ailleurs pas
de voir l'état intégrer leur capital
elles estiment pour la plupart que le
gouvernement ne les aide pas de bonne
manière elles souhaite en réalité
renforcer leurs fonds propres par
elles-mêmees ce qui passe par une
amélioration de leur marge rendu
impossible par le tour de vis fiscal
imposé dans le budget mes chers
collègues la création de richesse passe
effectivement par le dynamisme de nos
entreprises et il est bien sûr à
souhaiter que les initiatives
entrepreneuriales se multiplient dans
notre pays en revanche et il faut
l'accepter toutes les aventures ne sont
pas viables et c'est là tout le métier
du du banquier que d'évaluer la
pertinence de telle ou telle idée sur le
marché refuser que certaines entreprises
disparaissent c'est faire peser l'échec
des unes sur la naissance des autres et
les bonnes intentions d'une banque
publique qui financerait tout le monde
ne conduirait malheureusement pas à un
succès économique mais à socialiser les
pertes et privatiser les
profits le retour à une croissance forte
passera par notre capacité à inciter les
Français à investir et non à les
dissuader le retour à une croissance
juste passera par l'acceptation des
choix stratégiques des agents
économiques et surtout le retour à une
croissance saine passera par la
transparence et la sobriété de
l'utilisation de l'argent public je vous
remercie